in Washington President Trump says he
needs help from Republicans to fight off
the house impeachment inquiry the
president spoke to reporters for well
over an hour yesterday calling for
solidarity from his party ahead of
potentially damaging testimony on
Capitol Hill bill Taylor the top US
diplomat in Ukraine and a former
ambassador there will answer questions
from House Democrats this morning he
told a fellow ambassador it was crazy
that the White House withheld military
aid to push Ukraine's government to
conduct political investigations Paula
Reid is at the White House Paula what
else is the president saying
Anthony ahead of today's testimony the
president is lashing out at his usual
targets Democrats and the press but he's
also turning the heat on his own party
saying they need to do a better job of
defending him to me impeach is a very
ugly word President Trump
unleashed his frustrations in a new
interview with Fox News it really means
a high crime and misdemeanor that letter
is a perfect conversation earlier in the
day he went on the defensive against
Democrats I think they're lousy
politicians but two things they have
they're vicious and they stick together
they don't have Mitt Romney in their
midst senator Romney expressed concern
over acting chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
'he's confirmation last week that there
was a quid pro quo with Ukraine holding
up funds to a foreign nation
particularly one that's under military
threat in order to fulfill a political
purpose is a real problem the president
called on his party to do more to
support him they have to get tougher and
fight because the Democrats have tried
to hurt the Republican Party for the
election it was Republican criticism
that prompted mr. Trump to issue a rare
reversal of his plan to host the next g7
at his Florida resort you people with
this phoney of monuments laws that
Clause is part of the Constitution and
it prohibits any sitting US president
from accepting payments from foreign
governments you don't think I get enough
promotion I get more promotion
than any human being that's ever lived
adding to the president's woes today
will be that testimony from former
ambassador bill Taylor he is expected to
be a key witness in this impeachment
inquiry in text messages
Taylor expressed concern that the Trump
administration was withholding aid from
Ukraine in an effort to press its
government to pursue political
investigations Tony
very explicit messages indeed Paula
thank you very much